going to the phone line right now on the
mercedes-benz van phone line is our
friend none other than jay bilas of the
worldwide leader in sports how are you
jay
did will you miss him right there no
he's there
you there jay i guess so you and i are
gonna have to throw down here we go yes
we are there we go your phone was
cutting in and out but it came in just
at the right time for your punch line uh
or your slap line should we call it a
slap line what should we call it
yeah an open hand slap line okay
so um i'll give you the floor i saw your
tweets and your uh your instagram on it
but i give you the floor on what
happened at the end of wisconsin
yesterday and your your thoughts on it
yeah it was disappointing you know one
to see coaches who are supposed to be
the quote-unquote adults in the room to
act that way and and i don't let anyone
off the hook i mean i think there are
differing levels of culpability for the
incident but no one is blameless in it
and and it went beyond the incident
itself rich i think it was more not more
but after
after there had been a cooling off
period and the two coaches went in their
press conference neither one of them
expressed any sort of regret that the
incident happened at all
and and i didn't think that was the
right way to handle it and so i was
disappointed
you know that there's going to be some
some sanctions from it that the league
and the schools are going to break the
tape down like it's the zapruder film
um
but
and you don't want to overreact either
uh you know you hear some people calling
for juwan howard's firing other people
talking about suspensions the one thing
about
about a suspension is it hurts the
players more than anything
and if it's going to be long term so
hopefully cooler heads will prevail
afterwards
but i just don't think it's that
difficult whether you liked whether the
coach pressed or or whether the coach
calls a timeout the other coach
um
and and i i get a little tired of people
rationalizing behavior based upon well
i'm a competitor we're competitors the
competition was over and if you didn't
bring the fight in the competition you
know the next thing was the handshake
line behave yourself and i thought those
two coaches acted like babies frankly
and
and uh and now they're gonna now they're
gonna have to stand in the corner for a
little while so then wha what uh what do
you ascribe then to greg guard in
wisconsin of what he did uh awry here
jay there are many including people in
this room who think he has no
culpability in this so what do you have
for me on that front
i don't believe that there's no
culpability like there there's no reason
to stop someone that won't shake your
hand let them go by
um you know
these are these are can be tense
situations i am not saying
that grey guard is anywhere near as
culpable
as juan howard that's why i was saying
different levels of culpability but
nobody's blameless and the one the one
thing i would ask of both coaches and i
would have asked if i were a reporter in
the press conference is
are you proud of your words and actions
in that moment
and if the answer was anything other
than no that would be revelatory to me
um and look when you when
and it may be a small thing to some but
when you go into the press conference
and you are explaining like juan howard
should have been apologetic for his
behavior
and i think so should greg guard have
been and when you're when you're trying
to explain
what happened and you say maybe the
other coach didn't know the rule
my first reaction is really you think a
guy that's been in the game as long as
john howard didn't know the rule
um and i'm not a big fan of this
unwritten rule stuff
uh you know that that you don't you
don't press you don't you put your your
subs in or whatever there's nothing in
the rule book about that and if it's not
the rule book just deal with it and look
at the end of games all the time you see
teams take shot clock violations so they
don't shoot it
at the end of the game so the idea that
they would have a turnover
doesn't seem to me that big of a deal
but i don't care what happened in the
game the game was over
and there was no reason for for anyone
to behave that way and and whether great
guard was uh whatever you think his
level of culpability
it didn't look like those two were were
exchanging pleasantries after or or or
one was saying hey hey i'm sorry i'm
sorry i hope you didn't misunderstand
nothing like they they they got nose to
nose
and there's no there's just no reason
for it and and i i don't i don't excuse
anyone uh and again there's different
levels of culpability juwon howard being
at the highest rung of that ladder but
that doesn't mean everybody else that
it's okay because things were said there
and things were done
uh during and after that
that that i don't think we're right and
uh and i don't have any hesitation
saying this but but whatever whatever
the sanction is if it's anything less
than a player would get i think that's
wrong
so what do you think should be the
sanction jay what do you think i don't
know that's a great question i don't it
depends on what the the university's
values are and and and look these all
these administrators and universities
talk a great game
uh but oftentimes their actions don't
match with their rhetoric um to me it
does this doesn't rise to the level of
termination uh for john howard uh but if
there's a suspension i don't think it
needs to be a a long one i don't think
it would have to be a long one for a
player
and you know you you deal with what
happened so those who say it could have
been worse somebody could have been hurt
while nobody was so so it could have
been worse but it wasn't so let's deal
with what it was
and uh uh you know maybe a reprimand for
for some and and for for juan howard
maybe short suspension but you give him
a long suspension and what you're really
doing is hurting the players and the
players who actually competed it had
opponents like the coaches were in a
competition they don't have opponents
there's nobody trying to stop the coach
physically from calling a timeout or for
drawing up a play the players are the
ones that were physically on the line
there and they behaved well until the
coaches lost it and uh and and that that
that's where the problem is the the
match that was lit for that was lit by
the coaches not by the players jay bill
is here in the rich eisen show what do
you make of the
question about just eliminating the
handshake after the game would you be
for that or having this sort of spark
that conversation
not because of this uh rich but i've
never been a fan of the handshake line
i've always called it the little league
handshake line because when you are
when you're standing in a line how much
does the handshake really mean i mean it
turns into like a high five uh exercise
two four six eight who do we appreciate
with michigan michigan yay like i don't
like it what i like is after competition
when
one counterpart seeks out another and
they have a meaningful exchange in
handshake after the game like you see in
an nfl game i mean look i'm an old man
but when i played they didn't have these
handshake lines and we shook hands
afterwards and it meant something you
actually got to say something the other
person when you're when you're spending
one second shaking 30 you know one
second handshakes with 30 people uh to
me it doesn't have the same meaning but
whatever mechanism there is behave
yourself and that's not hard luckily we
don't have these situations that's why
we're we're talking about this
but i i can't remember which coach was
saying oh it's great guard was saying
was saying this momentarily overshadows
the fact we got a really good team we
played really well in the second half
it's not momentarily overshadowing it
nobody cares about any of that stuff
because of this
and and there and the truth is there was
no reason for it if they had a problem
with each other they could call after
the game
and have their little uh little hissy
fit on the phone
uh they didn't need to do that there and
uh and look i mean i i don't i'm not
saying that that all of us have these
interactions but
there's there's there was just no
there's no justifiable reason for it and
uh and i would think that that each
person involved would say
it hopefully would say if i had that to
do over again i would handle it
differently yeah neither of them said it
in the first blush yesterday neither of
them did and they had time rich like
they had time to meet with their staff
um they had time to get on the phone
with their ads
um it wasn't you know they went into a
press conference and sat down in front
of the press
and had a cool off period and they
didn't do it and and to me that that
sent you know that that made it worse
and that made me feel worse about it
that
that you know we're kind of dealing with
uh uh with the situation where folks
just didn't overall they didn't get it
now is it a capital crime no
and and and will we in the media glory
not glorify we're going to use this so
the next time they play this is going to
be this is going to be the lead into it
and so how much do we dislike it if
we're going to show like when somebody
runs out on the field during the game
right it's been network policy we don't
show it because we don't want to
encourage it we're going to show this
and and we're going to make a big deal
out of this because it hypes it and uh
and some people maybe maybe maybe it's a
a fair point but they say no i like this
i like the grit i like this i don't
think this is what competitors do
competitors bring the fight during the
competition and they're sportsmen like
when the competition is over because
they understand that we're going against
another great competitor and we can lose
that's possible
so i don't there there are a whole bunch
of levels where i don't like this and
and to me this isn't like
two older two older men
getting into a fracas when they have
security to pull them away from each
other if you want to argue after the
game the speech and debate team has
opening and if you want to if you want
to fight the golden gloves is taking
applications if you want to if you want
to play a basketball game they just
played one and and the deal after the
game is shake hands and move on and and
they didn't do it j bill is here on the
rich eisen show so let us uh move on for
the moment now and it's kind of a shame
too because now that the nfl season is
over and the nba all-star game break is
hitting like this is usually the time
when everybody kind of uh surfs back in
or really gets into college basketball
and then this is the first thing we're
talking about so
um
let's let's hit who you think uh has the
best chance to cut down the nets over
the next month and a half j bill
rich i think it's a different year than
last year where we had two teams that
stood out above the rest with gonzaga
and baylor that were head and shoulders
better than everybody i think this year
we've got about eight teams that are
title favorites i would say prohibited
favorites so i think that the champion
will probably come out of that eight
but uh all of them can lose in the sweet
16 too because they're not as powerful
as they were last year but they're very
good
i think gonzaga is the best offensive
team
i think auburn is the best defensive
team both of them are outstanding uh you
know you got arizona and ucla out of the
west that are excellent
purdue is up there i think duke is up
there so we've got a number of teams
that are really capable
but but all of them uh have have uh i
don't want to say flaws or a hole but
all of them aren't powerful enough to
say that they can they can have a bad
bad outing in the sweet 16 and survive
it um you're gonna have to come to play
in every game this year and uh and
you know it's just a different year and
and in one way it's beautiful like last
year i think if baylor or gonzaga had
been beaten before the final four i
would have been shocked by that and i
won't be shocked if any team gets beat
in in the sweet 16 this year uh because
it's that kind of year and it may make
it more delicious for a fan um i don't
know the answer to that because there's
no i i can't remember us having ever a
bad ncaa tournament but this is more
kind of a normal year
but gonzaga is not getting the credit
they deserve for being one of the one of
the truly great you know great teams
this year they're the best offensive
team and it's not even close they're
they're magnificent to watch and then of
course it's the final uh weeks of the
stellar all-time great career of coach k
um and i i want to play this sound bite
for the our audience
i i'm assuming you you heard it i don't
know uh you you travel around so did you
hear jj reddick um along with jason
tatum on his podcast did you hear this
excellent yeah
all right so this is a devoted listener
though of the old man in the three
podcast jj redick having fellow dukey
jason tatum on talking about
coach k in a timeout that he witnessed
when he returned just recently
uh with his kids and they were sitting
behind the bench
and heard this
exchange uh with coach k right in front
of him there was a timeout second half
and i could see it i mean the the body
language was bad on the court and
you know everybody runs back you sit
down and you wait for coach the coach
meets with the with shire and and chris
carowell and nolan
and he comes back to the huddle and all
he says is he looks at each kid
and he says
i hate your
faces
your
faces suck and then he walks away that
was the time out
and i i thought to myself man how many
times how many times did that happen
some similar version of that
jay does that sound familiar to you yeah
it does it does and that's sort of kind
of the the difficulty of of this last
season if you want to call it a
difficulty is
on one hand we are rightfully so
throwing rose petals at coach k's feet
but when people tell stories about you
know years ago or things that happen
when times get tough i i think sometimes
you know some people can take the wrong
thing from it
and you know coach k
is is an amazing competitor
and and we have had really difficult
times you know he is not perfect
um but he's as close to perfect as a
coach that i've ever seen
and and so
like some of these things being
discussed
and then especially the old-time stuff
coming out you know some people may
clutch their pearls and express you know
kind of uh
uh
discussed by it but
um
the players get together we laugh about
those things now uh about stuff that he
said that he said or did and uh and i i
for one love it but but you just don't
want people to take it the wrong way no
i love it too i used to have i had an
old school teacher at the mcdill school
of journalism who would treat all of us
as students as if we were employees by a
news director in the television world
and those are some very gruff people and
it rubbed some of the students the wrong
way i took it as to mean this is being
treated like an adult and this is the
way the world is the real world is i i
heard that tatum was laughing saying
that you know body language also was
very important to coach k and he's heard
that before i laughed i you know what
i'm saying like obviously
you know when a grown man says this to a
kid but this is a coach
player relationship here and their faces
needed to be told that and i found that
very funny
jay
yeah and and the stuff that that
happened years ago when he was younger
right um i'm sure that that he maybe
there were a few things he'd like to
have back or we all would uh when you
first start out but when i my first year
playing for him was his third year
and as a coach and my first ncaa
tournament game was his first
and so you know there were things that
happened in practice that if you told
the stories now people go well that
doesn't sound kosher that shouldn't be
said or but but it was it was in a
heated situation and and and it got the
point across and but there was never a
time rich
that i've always taken this from tony
dungy you can be demanding without being
demeaning
and coach k
may have used some salty language over
the years and and i do too i'm a
world-class curser but but i don't
remember a time where he was ever
demeaning whether he where he went to
your character he would he would go to
your play
and it would be about being the best
version of yourself
um but but he did say one time uh and he
was building us up he came in the locker
room and and called us out by name and
said i would rather have you than any
other he said to me i would rather have
you than any other big guy in the
country and after the meeting was over
mark allery said yep he'd rather have
you than david robinson that sounded
really credible
don't want weymouth is now i want billa
his credibility took a huge hit
i love that i guess before i let you go
how do you think he is approaching
uh the final weeks and then you just
said you shared the first ncaa
tournament game of his career together
these will be his last
how do you think he's approaching it jay
yeah he just had his second to last home
game against florida state
and the last home game that he'll ever
coach on the floor at cameron indoor
stadium will be against north carolina
on saturday march 5th and and i'll be
there there'll be a probably 100 former
players and who knows how many
dignitaries and the like
um but i think it'll be intensely
emotional and he'll do his best to
manage it and try to keep it away from
the players but it'll be inescapable
um it'll it like the tickets some of the
tickets are going for 20 000 bucks
and i started thinking you know i got a
seat in the booth but for 20 000 i might
want to give that thing up and watch
watch it on tv but but it'll be it'll be
an unbelievable happening but he won't
be able to escape the emotion uh but i
know from knowing him so so long i know
he'll manage it the best that it can be
managed
uh but it'll it'll be a lot of a lot of
fun to to watch and to uh
to reminisce and all that i'm going to
be up there early and i'm probably going
to stay late because there'll be so many
former players there so
i'll probably tip a few back with them
as soon as the game's over well look for
my call jay i want to be a fly on that
wall that's for damn sure man and i
appreciate the two cents today as always
always a pleasure brother and uh and
again
do not ever violate the unwritten rule
of broadcasting by
by promoting another interview while
mine's coming up because we will throw
down in two seconds and it will not be
an open hand
you know what jay let's just uh agree to
just blow by each other right now and
and and
and have an offline conversation just
for the kids sake you know what i'm
saying not around the kids
take care of yourself jay you're the
best
take care that's jay bilas at jay bilas
follow him i should i uh you should if
you don't i do already hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here